- Hello Believe Nation.
I am Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all the major
problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey,
I'm going to share today the seven ways
that smart people stay calm.
And as always guys, as you're listening,
if you here something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
And the more you write
it down for yourself,
the more likely it's going
to stick in here as well.
Enjoy.
- [Distorted Voice] Nine.
Eight.
(electronic hiphop instrumental)
Rule number on is have a schedule.
One of the things that
really helped me stay calm
with all the things that were
happening in my business,
was to have a schedule and
I know that there's a time
for the thing that is causing an issue.
And so for example,
Tuesday is my YouTube day.
It's when I review all
the videos from my team.
It's when I answer any questions,
when I do setups for collaborations,
when I'm doing the research.
Anything basically YouTube
related except for filming,
I do on a Tuesday.
And so whenever I get
emails during the week,
I get questions, I get
proposals, I get ideas.
I review a video that then
spawns another creation.
I have a place.
I put it in my folder
and I know on Tuesday,
I'm going to have time to go and do it
and I think often times,
when we don't have time
to figure it out and we
try to rush to solve it,
it creates chaos, it creates stress,
but knowing that you have
a place in your calendar
to be able to do it,
for me at least, creates
a great sense of calm.
Number two is create a no-crisis business.
This is a huge thing I'm a
fan of as an entrepreneur.
I hate having to deal
with crisis, crisises.
Crises?
I hate having to deal
with crises in the moment.
I hate having a crisis business
and so it's the reason
why I don't use the phone.
Because what happens
when you have a phone?
People call you.
People call you with what
they think is an emergency
but it's really they're
use for your time, right?
It's their agenda for your
time instead of you saying
I'm protecting my time and
I'm focusing on the things
that really matter to me.
And so, sometimes this means
you have to fire clients.
You know, if I look at my main business,
most brands who approach me
with a deal, I don't work with.
Some of them just have
the wrong intentions,
but some of them are just too needy.
If you need me to be on
call 24-7 for your project
to be a success,
we're not going to work well together.
That deal is not going to happen.
Because I want to create
a no-crisis business
and sometimes that means
you lose opportunities.
Sometimes that means that I
will miss media opportunities
as an example because the
reporter's on a tight deadline
and needs an answer by 4:00 today
and I didn't even get the email
until two o'clock the next day.
Sometimes, that happens but you
have to be willing to let go
of the good to go for the great.
I'm using that time with
intention to focus on big,
most important projects for my company,
as opposed to only
dealing with little fire
after little fire, after little fire.
So as much as possible,
create a no-crisis business.
Number three is close
your eyes and breathe.
This sounds like a
pretty basic one but just
reminding yourself that this is stressful.
I'm going to breathe.
I'm going to close my eyes.
I'm going to relax.
And things start to get better.
Why do people go outside for a smoke?
The nicotine helps but
it's also the breathing.
And so if there's a
reminder on your calendar
or something on your desktop background
or whenever you feel that
stress coming on board,
just reminding yourself,
I'm going to close my eyes.
I'm going to take a
couple of deep breaths.
I'm going to instantly feel
a little bit more calm.
- So rule number four
is to have perspective.
I think a lot of the times,
we get really focused
on the nitty gritty of things,
of things that are happening.
You have emails coming through.
You have telephone calls coming through.
And we lose perspective
on what's important.
So just last night, I was
ready to teach my Zumba class.
I had my laptop ready,
everything was ready to go.
I have my playlist.
Everything is going as planned.
10 minutes before my class
starts, my laptop shuts down.
It just shuts down completely
and I started to panic
and I couldn't turn it back on
and immediately my thought was, oh my God,
this happens to me all the time.
Why does technology hate me so much?
This has happened before.
Many times.
And then I started replaying
all these weird things happening,
like what if the girls
come in and I don't have
the right playlist and then what do I do?
What if I forget everything?
What if I have no music?
Oh God, do I go on
YouTube to download music.
What is it?
And I just started spiraling
and spiraling out of control
and I felt a physiological
change in my body.
I started turning really red and I felt
a sickness come over my stomach.
I'm like oh gosh.
This is anxiety.
It's happening again.
I'm getting anxious.
And at that point, I took five minutes.
I was like okay, I'm going
to give myself five minutes.
I'm going to go in the back room
and put things in perspective.
It's a laptop.
It's fine.
It shut down, it's okay.
I have another playlist on my phone.
Yes, it's an old playlist
and I haven't done it since
a year ago, but I still have a playlist.
It's going to be fine.
What's important is that
I have a group of students
coming in with giant
smiles on their faces,
wanting to do Zumba,
want to get a nice workout.
And want an environment that
is suportive and encouraging
and I want them to feel
like they could love
all of themselves.
And me concerned about a
laptop or how technology's
always after me and
nothing can ever get done
because technology hates me,
is not going to help my situation.
So that five minutes, I calmed down.
I put things in perspective
and five minutes later
I found my old playlist.
I played it.
It wasn't ideal but it
was still an amazing class
and everyone left really, really happy.
So next time you feel like things are
spiraling out of control,
and you can't keep focus
and things are going wrong,
just remember to put
everything in perspective.
Number five is change your environment.
So sometimes, just getting
up and going for a walk
really helps.
I would find myself sometimes
getting stressed out
at my old office and
especially on a nice day,
I would spend 15 and
just go for a quick walk,
clear my head.
I really actually found that
helpful between switching tasks
so if I had to go from writing
something really intense,
that I had a 90-minute chunk to work on,
and then I had to switch
to some other task,
I would use that 15
minutes to clear my head,
to just change my environment
and to set myself up
to have success for
that next chunk of time.
I find that sometimes it's the
people right in front of you
or the environment that triggers you
and just going for a walk and changing it
can help bring you a sense of calm.
Number six is remember your why.
Another thing I find really
helpful is remembering
what I'm doing, why is this so important?
Who am I trying to help?
What's my mission?
And so, if you're dealing
with some little stress
that might be overwhelming in the moment,
thinking about I'm
doing this thing because
I wanted to help entrepreneurs,
because my work matters.
Because people leave
comments on all these videos
and say how important a lot
of these videos are to them
to stay motivated, to give them ideas
to continue to build amazing things.
And so, the stress of one
hater or a video not being
ready on time or having to
switch around the schedule,
those kinds of things
that can happen are small
in comparison to the why of
what I'm trying to accomplish
and keeping that focus and
whenever I'm kind of stressed out,
remembering back to, why am I doing this?
Why is this so important to me?
Helps put those other
things not seem so big.
And number seven is meditate.
And I put this at number seven
because I don't really meditate.
I've never found a way to
really make it work for me,
but it works for other
people so I had to include it
on the list.
For whatever reason, I've really wanted
to learn to meditate.
I've been on and off with
meditation for, I don't know,
at least a decade.
I just don't feel the benefit of it.
I really want to though.
I remember we went to
this Tony Robbins event
a month or two ago in California.
And they had this meditation guy come on
and we were supposed to meditate.
We're supposed to feel this
ball of energy between us
and he was like, how many
of you can feel the ball?
And (grumbling) I don't feel the ball.
Where's the ball, where's the ball?
I can't feel the ball.
(laughing)
I'm getting stressed out
trying to feel the ball.
And then the next exercise,
you had to stand up
and put your hand over somebody's
head and feel the energy
field over the head.
And I can't feel the energy field.
How many of you guys
feel the energy field?
Everybody shoots up their hand.
And I'm like I can't
feel the energy field.
So I don't know why.
I think maybe in general,
I'm just pretty calm.
I don't get stressed out that easily,
but I'm going to add it on the list
and hopefully maybe you guys will give me
a resource that I can use,
finally the resource
that will click with me
so that meditation can be
an important part of my daily routine.
So that's my take on the seven ways
that smart people stay calm.
I'd love to know, what did you guys think?
Which way was most relevant,
impactful, valuable to you?
Leave it down in the comments below.
Also, is there any eight,
nine, 10 that I missed
that you want to add to the
list that really helped you,
please share it because I think it'll help
a lot of entrepreneurs who are
watching this video as well.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.